but we do want to begin with that
horrible news coming to us out of
houston texas today at least eight
people are many others injured after
what officials describe as a crowd surge
at the astroworld music festival that
caused some panic
and it started causing some injuries
people began to fall out
become unconscious
and it created additional additional
panic
now these are just some of the latest
images coming into our newsroom as they
show an ambulance and first responders
in the midst of a sea of people as they
care for those who were crushed
in that huge absurd but earlier in the
day possible warning signs of a
situation spinning out of control
hundreds of festivalgoers storming past
security surging through metal detectors
and stepping over each other to get into
the sold out concert at least 300 people
were treated at field hospitals on the
site and we know from some eyewitnesses
that the crowd was densely packed it was
a sold out crowd of 50 000 people
obviously everybody's opening up mosh
pits we're having a good time but
there's a lot of people that are very
selfish there's people that that i saw a
pit that was being held together by
people but because the p in the pit was
people that fell
so they were helping they were standing
together to help the people get up and
i've witnessed and i witnessed somebody
unconscious
struggling to get out like their friends
were trying to get him out and just
people weren't caring enough to like
make a path so
as i'm a 400 pound guy
so i jump in
because that's just my instinct
and i just make a i make a path for him
and on my way back to the middle i mean
a girl that's
hyperventilating
so it said like you know i couldn't tell
her hey calm down i immediately just
grab her and i'm rushing back
and you know closer to the vip section
that's when it's like this you know well
in the front there was a definitely a
lot of jump if you didn't jump you were
gonna fall and you would get trampled on
definitely so the crowd's pushing yeah
the crowd's pushing back and forth like
you needed to if you were even a little
bit tired you were going to fall it was
just too insane
so you tried to get your buddy yeah so
my buddy was there and he was already
passing out he i saw him i noticed him
on someone's back and then right away he
said that he wanted to go and i just
helped him out there's a video i watched
and
um
yeah i can't show it i can't show it but
essentially you
such a weird cell phone video so in the
video itself the guy's kind of filming
the concert and then he pans to the left
you go watch some tmz
and you see somebody laid out on the
floor and there's a paramedic doing cpr
and the person is just out cold and the
individuals
judging by the video i'm pretty sure the
person's dead
and the person
so weird they pan back towards the main
stage and there's this girl just being
left
and and literally like five feet on the
floor there's a there's a dead person
and it just that image
is kind of seared into my brain because
it kind of perfectly illustrates
the event there's people so being
preoccupied with their own enjoyment and
their own pleasure and their own like
i'm here i'm trevor scott that they
forget
how to be human a little bit and
in their defense you know when you're
caught up in the euphoria of being at a
live event and that energy and you're
there to party and you're inebriated and
you know let's also not kill ourselves a
lot of people are on some stuff
you're not in the best state to be
considerate or to take care of other
people
um
but at the same time it's just like bro
this person's passed out dying right
beside you and you're just like
it's just
yeah it just felt like we was like
literally like in [ __ ] hell bro like
it felt like we was in a concert in hell
you couldn't breathe you couldn't see
like just imagine all the people they're
gonna find tonight who was in that crowd
who nobody could see who nobody could
hear who passed out and everybody was
just troubling on top of them the whole
[ __ ] concert like
in the vip section it was so many bodies
laid out
people was getting pulled out who was
fainted
and the people were trying the medicine
trying to give them cpr and they was
flipping them over and like they was
literally turning black and blue like i
never seen no i've never seen death in
my [ __ ] life bro
just by me alone it was probably like
10 [ __ ] people laid out dead and like
once the medic tried to help them they
wasn't responding they moved to the next
person it was nothing they couldn't do
like this [ __ ] like this [ __ ] really
[ __ ] me up and i really spooked me
tonight like that was like some demonic
[ __ ] and what was so crazy like people
were screaming help trying to tell
scratch travis scott it was like help
the whole crowd was just going to help
help help he just kept going bro and
mind you y'all see the type of music i
make y'all see everything like you know
like i've been so heavily influenced by
travis but like
after tonight bro like god really showed
me like you know like stay away from
that [ __ ] but like that [ __ ] not for you
cuz like he sacrificed so many people's
lives tonight like for real
like so many people lives
are gone tonight because they want to go
to the [ __ ] travis scott concert and
have fun you know he influenced people
to be raging and all this [ __ ] so many
people broke in and it was just chaos
bro it was a living [ __ ] hell bro
there's a lot of people that want to
hold travis scott accountable because he
kept this show going while people were
dying
he passed out
right here hold on don't touch him don't
touch him
real quick
listen
you guys are having this information
that people are dying but he's on stage
he does from the stage you don't know
the serious of what's going on yeah i
remember i was doing a show and i was
right on the north shore
i was opening i was the opening after
that show
and
i'm on the show and i hear some i hear
something it's not a band it's not music
it's just me doing comedy and there's
someone that said something in the room
and i didn't hear what it said at first
i thought it was a heckler but it was
actually someone passing out and that
was there was that that split moment
where i didn't even know what was going
on and i thought it was a heckler and i
was about to go in on this [ __ ]
disrupting what i was saying
on the stage you don't know what's going
on you don't see everything that's going
on so
i wouldn't necessarily yeah also people
passing out at concerts is very normal
you know being at the front for a big
stage show you got to sit there and wait
there standing for hours and boo boo as
you're jumping up and everyone around
you shoulder to shoulder okay and
they're stealing the oxygen it's getting
hotter and you're not well hydrated
passing out is extremely common now with
this crowd it seemed like they were
extra rowdy mosh pits everybody moving
against each other and you know listen
there's normally an etiquette to these
kind of things if somebody's passed out
normally people make a way i've seen
mosh pits before and if somebody gets
knocked out everybody traditionally
bands together this one didn't seem to
be the case and for a lot of people
that's why they were passing out
um you know people are dying of cardiac
arrest young people that's how stressful
and
tiring the event must have been so i can
only imagine being in that kind of sea
it's okay i'm pretty big i could like
hold myself you know hold my elbows i'll
not get hold that but someone that is
smaller i could i i could see it being a
challenge you know what though
even in your circumstances if the crowd
is rowdy yeah that you don't think you
could do
because it's not one person because the
person pressing against you you're like
pushing back but then there's a wave of
people pressing on them right and here's
the thing in those kind of circumstances
once you fall [ __ ]
you're not strong good luck getting
what i'm saying is that i still have
better chances i'm not saying that i'm
here i'm not saying that i'm
immune to this [ __ ] yeah i'm i got
better chances but if i'm down down
i got more chances but it's like it's
almost a wrap because it's not just one
person yeah people step in people that
are stepping over you because
everybody's like that they don't even
see you no
no
so it's not like they can
watch and be like oh careful no
it's one and one person down trips
another one trips another one
it's it's
it's not cute i'm personally
do not do giant crowds
that's not me
you don't catch me at no concerts and if
you do best believe i'm staying in the
way way back where there's an open area
really but that's just kind of how i am
and this is not to say i'm one better
it's just i never feel at ease
being like
with everybody up on me and this is not
my thing i don't like being in crowds
like that to me it's like i just i can't
do it he said he doesn't do big crowds
he doesn't do medium crowds let's be
honest it's not big cry it's medium yeah
i remember when i went to carnival in
brazil
and i was in those big ass crowds you're
talking about like streets jam-packed
shoulder or shoulder if you want to walk
like and i'm good at clearing crowds
like i understand how to move through
them
um but when i was down there i remember
every time i would put myself anytime i
had to be in that crowd because the
person i was with they really wanted to
go
i remember positioning my back to a
place where there wasn't just people
behind me yes there was either a
vehicle or there was evil a wall or
whatever it's just like maybe it's just
the way my brain functions but every
time i'm like you do not want to be
surrounded and helpless no you don't if
you guys are at a concert and someone's
passed out do what you can to make space
for that person to be able to leave
adequately
right sometimes just because they're
asleep doesn't mean they're sleeping
they might be dying okay and so just be
considerate of that and try to take
take
understand you're there for your
enjoyment that's cool but be considerate
of the people around kids the only thing
i would say other than that um
yeah this is tragic man it's just tragic
when it comes to these things
even though there's a lot of life
doesn't mean that somebody's always at
fault
but anyways let us know what you guys
think of the comments below we want to
hear from you guys